yeah welcome to this video I'm you for
played in a five minute game and let's
go Cal com got to practice what you
preach okay so let's go to let's go
Braun Bronstein Larson Bronstein Larson
Bishop to c4 yeah of course I also had
this in my in my videos but i forgot
what to reply 97 to be 6 may or just
Bishop to c5 mmm the Bishop c4 is not
super dangerous but it probably is if
you forget what is what's good okay I
spent too much time already it's it's
five minutes not 15 if you play a couple
of at least as its move this off my
problem if you play a couple of games
and then one time control to adjust back
to UM to the other okay go into 2d two
and ok it's a bit of a problem i cannot
cannot really play em kaplan 97 or 96
and i don't want want to take yeah maybe
i need to provoke him and and grant him
give him this this temple but i don't
don't see anything terrible happening to
black in this position anyway i can just
cancel long and play rook to 2g eight or
play against e for the spawn center with
the double pawns is some is quite
resilient okay so d5 young he wants to
play d5 if I castle long
five ok I can I can play this move first
it's not bad anyway uh huh
ok
I'm not sure is it really as idea to UM
to grab age five maybe it is him okay
but i can i can still first castle go
into f3 yeah i was thinking queen a d5
but now that i look at it a bit more
closely i see that he may be can take
this pawn between a 2 mm that's also
look III and it's not so clear what this
all is doing hmm down to 2 30 that's not
good
yeah I'm not I'm not sure about this
position anyway
yeah was threatening him night night
before and what now is this CC for
communion okay anyway trying to get
compensation on the to open to open file
CM c 4 i'm yeah i was thinking worked
you form yeah come I don't have so much
time yep and now queen and for this was
my idea hoping to gain again enough
counter play can take here if he wants
and then I'm two points down but I'm
attacking h4d for f2 so i will get 1
pound bag and i hope that i'm active
enough to to put up to put up a fight
IAM saudi six
yes is his idea
okay but if i take it takes XD 6 look
back it's it's not clear right I just
get it back I had the anti Scott of
course two against one on the queenside
so maybe this was was really terrible ah
and I also could have taken f2 maybe
okay d 6 I can also play king see aid
blocking this with the King and then try
to get counter play with the rook yeah
it's not so okay okay yeah
and you don't want to give them two
connected passed pawns but yeah I don't
want to go i canna cannot go on the
eighth-ranked this is really not on
check
this way at least them I've got to have
gotten um a pest porn
check
check
check
yeah and now I'm that the only chance
hi morning they had the stupid meet
ideas I really am really the problem
yeah it's a very easy win actually yeah
just give me 70 okay come on Oh jump
interesting yeah maybe around him I need
to improve I don't think that this
should be so terrible for black at this
position of course I had 25 as I saw
this also i mean a to hangs AG two eggs
it's not exactly rocket science but
maybe let's check it with the computer I
are 25 is probably the bastion okay but
I still I'm not totally convinced that
this this this was bad what I played
maybe it was I mean you can sir it's
difficult yeah now a computer wants to
retreat which is of course not the idea
this was the IDM it takes yeah okay of
course this this is bad in a way that
black can never be better here it's just
a question can you somehow get into a
tenable endgame here I wonder if I was
maybe having some chances to do to do it
maybe look after we are yeah this is
real problem I mean I don't have a good
square toe it's just a pawn down so with
a pawn down in rook endgame you always
have some chances but what what I don't
have a move I cannot I cannot really go
back I mean I can but this is just bad
and gameplay in the rook
game maybe I must root King be eight but
what a move no I must I must ride that
and of course he played some crap yeah
kicking c2 is just nonsense Moscow king
d to this was clear this is this gives
me some some chances again and round
here may be gay look at the coffee
evaluation he he brought this down to
0.6 from plus 3 but um it's still good
for wider 22 connected passed pawns yeah
come here he ever far beyond far beyond
salvation yeah probably a probably just
just just 25 m
in this position checking those two
pawns and this is just more exact what
what is why do know I was thinking that
this move might be a problem because I
cannot take him and this is this is just
just too stupid but I can I can I can
cancel and then this is just a better
version of the game with with no big
problems white can play something don't
know something like this and this this
is a playable position for black those
pawns are not not a big issue yeah an
interesting game thanks for watching